[Music]
john is with us to start off this hour
in tulsa oklahoma hi john welcome to the
ramsey show
hey dave thanks for having me sure
what's up
good to talk to you today um
we
i'm in a bit of a mess i
i moved for i moved from
texas in
january
and of 2021 this year
and
that's the first time we've moved out
away from from everyone
um
first time we had left the city that we
we
spent our whole lives in
and so we took a big leap of faith and
got out here to tulsa and um
we've just really
really kind of gotten ourselves in a
bind
i was i was listening to you hard and
heavy for about three months straight
before we before we moved and we had big
big plans to
sit down and talk through some things
and figure some stuff out and we didn't
and i made a lot of dumb decisions since
then
and we are in all kinds of debt
we've got from credit cards to loans to
student loans car payments
and we're just in over our heads so
so deep that we're trying to figure out
what to do you know
[Music]
so if you were completely free would you
move back home
i don't think so
okay
so what is the
was just the stress of being away from
what was uh
familiar you think that added to the bad
decisions is that why you're telling us
about that part of it
yes definitely i do believe so there was
there's a lot of uh with my wife and i
we
we
we let we we pastored for several years
and
for five years and and so we were out of
ministry for one year and we
we fully believe god spoke to us to move
to tulsa
[Music]
did you take did you take another pastor
right there
no i did not um i'm also a plumber i've
i've i'm a i've got a master license in
texas i have a business there still that
generates a little bit of money um and
i've worked for a plumbing company here
in this area
um
my wife is not working right now but
she's she's about to go back to work and
so that's going to help us a lot i know
what do you make now
probably about i make about 78 with with
one the one company it's probably close
to 100 combined and what does she what
will she make
um we'll probably be in the 100 i would
say 100 to 120 range together combined
all right i'm going to call it 120
because you told me 100 for you said she
went back to work all right so
yeah um now
how much
is your house payment
it's 14.50 a month okay and what do you
owe on the cars
each
now okay 42 000
on one
and i took out a loan a person a couple
of personal loans and one of them is
tied to my truck mount and so that one
that holds about 12 000.
okay and you already had student loans
before you moved
yes and how much are the the student
the student loans they equal about 60
000.
did you say each
uh they they're about they total about
they total about 60. okay so 42 12 and
60. what other debts
um oh credit cards more loans
credit cards are probably about 8 000.
um somewhere in there maybe a little
less loans are around 20 000
just personal loans
yes okay
so how much of this did you do since you
moved
um the the student loans in one car were
previous the big car that was all
previous
about half of the credit cards were
previous the new loans and credit card
debt is since we made
okay
so how can i best help you
we're i just i don't even know we're
we're just such at such a loss right now
and and
there was a lot of bad decisions like i
said that that combined us together
making dumb dumb things and
we we finally got back to church um we
just i'm wondering if there's like a
group here in tulsa that we can
find that that is a ramsay group is
there a way to find that sure we'll just
put you into uh ramsey plus into um
you know financial peace university and
there's a lot of churches teaching that
live and you can plug into that i'll pay
for that and help you get started um
okay
your language covers
the words you're using and the way
you're using them covers a lot of other
mistakes that aren't financial it sounds
like
yeah there there has okay there's been
some different okay let's just leave
that there because
the weight of this doesn't the weight of
this in your voice doesn't really match
your numbers that's why i was asking so
um so what if i said uh okay we're going
to get really together uh you and your
wife are going to work tight together
you're going to be on beans and rice
rice and beans you're not going to see
the inside of a restaurant unless you
work there and you're not going on
vacation and you're selling her stupid
butt 42 000 car what if i said that
that that's
we're we're on board we're we're ready
we we're both ready but we've just been
talking about it and we're ready to do
it now yeah yeah you got to start doing
some stuff that's going to hurt
yeah there's some pain involved in
living like no one else so that later
you can live and give
like no one else and then and we're
ready
yeah we just need some help to get
started i believe and okay you're gonna
sell a bunch of crap and you're gonna
cut your lifestyle to nothing
yeah you've been you've been eating
candy so much you've got a stomach ache
what amounts to
yes
like yeah like i take one of my
grandkids to the ice cream store and let
them just you know completely founder
themselves and then they're on a sugar
high and their belly hurts right
yes
and i you know what i
john i'm i'm just going to say this i'm
not going to make you respond to it but
i think it's time for you and your wife
to forgive
yourselves there's some shame there's
some pain that's driving some of these
decisions at some point you're going to
have to say god still loves us we still
have a lot of value to ourselves to our
family to our friends to him
you need to forgive yourself and and
move forward today plumbers are as
valuable to the kingdom of god as
preachers are yeah
well and you don't have to be a preacher
for god to love you yeah
matter of fact i'm pretty sure god might
love some plumbers more than some
preachers
i could attest to that day from personal
experience i'll just leave it at that